- Welcome.
(crowd applauding)
It's really hard to
see everybody out there
with the lights on, but
I hear you out there.
So thank you for coming.
We appreciate your
attendance and attention.
My name is Ben Schreiner.
I'm the head of AI
and Modern Data Strategy
Business Development at AWS,
and I welcome you to our session.
I'll ask my good friend
Michael to introduce himself.
- Hello, everybody, and
thanks for being here.
Michael Bachman.
I run research at Boomi.
This is market, technical,
and all things geopolitical
research as well.
It's a lot of fun,
and I've been doing that for quite a bit.
- My name is Barry Gerdsen.
I'm the channel CTO for Boomi.
I've been with Boomi for eight years now
and really excited to be
here before you all today.
- All right, let's start
with a little audience participation
and make sure you're
all alive and well here.
So if we could pull up the first question,
and we'll do a raise hand queue here
to see if any of you have
an executive mandate.
Anyone?
Okay, that's probably half.
We'll call it half, all right.
- Half, yeah.
- We're trying to gauge the
audience so that we can tailor
the messaging at the right
altitude for the audience.
So bear with us.
We've got a couple more questions for you.
Any of you deliberately
actually on purpose
using AI or agentic systems at work?
Okay, awesome.
Anybody that has an agent
doing their whole job for them right now?
Not yet.
All right, good to see.
Thank you for laughing, whoever did.
That was a joke.
And lastly here, if you could,
let's raise our hands way up
if you're super concerned.
Halfway up if you're kind of concerned.
And if you're not concerned at all,
just keep your hands down.
All right, we have a level of concern.
All right, there we go.
All right, that definitely helps us gauge
the rest of this talk with
our esteemed guest here.
All right, I think we can advance.
- Oh, yeah, let's advance this way.
- Yeah, or forward backwards.
- Ah, whatever.
- Chacha here at the...
Here's our agenda, if we will.
We're gonna walk through we
all five of these pillars.
The first half of the conversation
will be between myself and Michael,
and then we'll pivot to Barry's
content to bring us home.
And gentlemen, please feel free to augment
each other's answers as you see fit.
- Thank you.
- All right, so without further ado,
if you could, Michael,
what is an agent, really?
- Yeah, so...
Okay, so we all have a general definition
of an agent, right?
In the before times, we
called it a computer program.
And so I like to think
of it as nothing more
than a computer program
with a different layer of
computation, access to tools,
and also something in the environment
that's it's going to learn from.
And so before we can even
talk about what an agent is,
I like to talk about agency in general,
and that's what these five pillars are.
So there's some level of autonomy
that this computer
program is going to have.
And there's a neat slide that
we'll show in just a minute
talking about our trust
versus autonomy as well.
But planning and reasoning
is something that an
agentic system will do.
And predominantly, that's going to be
with the kind of computational
architecture that we have,
as you all know, with generative AI.
But this could also be discriminative AI
in the mix as tooling.
But realistically, planning and reasoning
seems to be largely offloaded
to these types of generative systems
that are sort of the
brains of these agents.
Humans are agents, of course,
and we plan and reason on our own as well,
in maybe a different way than the model
that we use in the box is,
but that's one area.
Another area is being
reactive and proactive
in a particular environment.
So being reactive to
something like a prompt
versus proactive, like taking a prompt,
inferring what's meant and
going and finding extra answers.
Just as an example,
learning and adaptation
is also part of a part
of what it means to be
an agentic system of
some kind or have agency.
And so this learning and
adaptation changes over time.
How we learn what intelligence is.
These are all open
questions now in research,
in academic research and otherwise,
but this is important to know
because these agents and agentic systems
that we're creating, if we
want them to emulate humans
and what it means to be human,
we have to think about
how we learn and adapt
before we can truly accept and trust
how a non-human based
agentic system will act.
And that all is boiled down
to how oriented to a goal
the agent really is.
And so this question of alignment
is something that we
need to be thinking about
in the audience.
I do have another polling question.
- Yeah, please fire away, yeah.
So, of you all, how many of you work
on fine-tuning models or
creating models for agents,
or not even agents, just generative AI?
Do I have any data scientists in the room?
- All right.
- Okay.
- I got one.
- Yeah.
- Who here is using an agent right now?
Like, actively.
All right, couple.
Good, good, good.
Who here wants to use an agent,
and that's why you showed
up to this session?
Excellent, lots of more hands going up.
All right, so we're on the learning curve
for most of the audience.
So that helps us set the right altitude
for the rest of the talk.
And so the next question
I have for you, Michael,
if I could, is, what are important factors
one needs to consider when using an agent?
So most of us aren't in
the audience, but want to,
so what should they be considering
as they go down this path?
- Okay, so there was a slide
that was out of order,
so forgive me for going back.
This one right here.
- There we go.
- So there was an MIT survey
that was conducted,
and you probably have seen
something similar to this,
where 19 out of 20 projects fail,
and failed to make it out of pilot.
So I was at MIT a couple of weeks ago,
working with some
scientists and stuff there.
And while I was there, it was
with the scissor researchers,
not the same people who
conducted this particular survey.
However, the survey really
boils down to a couple of things
that are of concern if
we want to use agents.
And one of them is,
integration is a big problem.
So giving any type of
software system access to data
or information that could be used in a way
that is not deterministic is one barrier,
but not being able to integrate
with those data sources is one big issue.
The second big issue
with this particular
survey and others as well,
is that, culturally, two things.
One, there has to be ROI attached
to what these agentic
systems are going to do.
If there's no value, it
becomes a science project.
And right now, a lot of
pressure is being put on boards,
it's being put on executives,
and it's being put on people like us
who are operators within our business,
trying to bring these things to light.
The second thing of, you
know, the cultural shift
is we have to think about new
ways to employ these systems.
Up until now, all of the
software that we've been building
has been largely deterministic.
And because of that, we have rules.
If this condition exists, then do this.
Otherwise, do this other thing, right?
And so with that code,
we can be very, you know,
very logical and targeted.
- Explicit.
- Yep, and very explicit on
what the outcome is going to be.
We also have to have a margin of error
when we think of these
non-deterministic systems.
And so if we're going to introduce
a generative type of computational model
into a software program,
we have to be comfortable
with some level of risk
and also some level of variance
for what our expectation is.
And so what that also means is,
the way that we have
done things in the past
might not be the best
way to solve something.
- To go forward.
- And so if we're going
to use an agentic system,
we also have to be comfortable
with our deterministic answers,
not necessarily being the right way
to go about solving a
problem in a novel way.
And so the last thing I'll say
just on this one topic as well,
the really, really cool
thing I think that agents
and generative AI brings us
is the ability to fail fast.
And when we think about failing,
to me, that is a feedback
loop of learning.
And I tell my kids that all of the time.
Failure is learning.
So as long as you learn from your,
you know, whatever happened before
and you update the weights in your head,
I don't necessarily say that
to them exactly like that,
but this is essentially
how we're going to learn
and adapt in our world.
The great thing I think
about generative systems
is that we can fail fast and
prototype quickly and move on.
The downside is, we can fail fast.
And if we're putting a lot of weight
on what these agents and
agentic systems are doing,
it can also cause side
effects that we don't expect
in the business as well.
So, don't go into production right away.
- Yeah, Barry, something to add?
- So is it fair to say then, Mike,
that maybe within this 95% statistic,
these 19 out of 20 that
aren't, or failing, let's say,
that there's room for AI agents
that might do analysis of the failures
to be able to make some of those
or to be able to rectify,
maybe even autonomously,
some of the failures that happen to have
within that 19 or 20 that you find?
- Sounds like you're leading the witness,
but, yeah, I think so.
(Barry laughs)
Yeah, so we can use our agents
to be able to assess and evaluate,
you know, failure
conditions, risk conditions,
anything that's going to
potentially be deleterious
you know, to an objective.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Cool.
- Our next question,
"Why Boomi for agents?"
- Right.
So, for those of you who
have built agents so far,
have you used open source systems
like open source agent builders?
Has anybody used like
Salesforce to build an agent?
It's okay, I know we're
at an AWS conference.
(Barry laughs)
It's okay.
How about AWS?
Have you built agents
in AWS at this point?
It's a pretty good
platform, I'll say that.
And one thing about Boomi,
we're built on top of AWS as well.
The idea though is that Boomi
is really focused not
only on agent builds,
but on observability and
governance of agents.
And so a lot of the things that we can do
or when you make agents,
we can give you oversight.
And Barry's gonna talk a a little bit more
about this in a bit.
But think of it as like, when
we go to McCarran Airport,
or what used to be McCarran,
I think it's something else now.
But whatever, the airport
here in Las Vegas,
there's a control tower there
and it's monitoring all
of the flight traffic
regardless to which airlines
we're talking about.
In the same way,
our control tower monitors
agents of different types,
tailing logs, looking
at how different agents
interact with each other.
These are just examples of
one thing that we need to do
in order to help our customers govern
their agentic landscape, whatever
that's going to look like.
- Gotcha.
- Yeah, Barry.
- Yeah, I mean if even thinking
about autonomous agents
and things that will
execute, well, autonomously,
you start to think about, if
you didn't have governance,
what the implications would be?
And, you know, anyone who's
seen an autonomous process
or, let's say, something
that didn't have a human
in the loop happen,
where that can go wrong.
Just start to think about,
well, what happens now if
we have some of these agents
which, you know, can have
a degree of variability?
You introduce that into this,
you know, agent calling,
another agent calling,
another agent making choices,
how that could potentially go wrong.
You really start to understand
how a human in the loop
is kind of necessary just to make sure
or mitigate the risk involved.
- So for the audience, help
us understand how Boomi
is differentiated in this space.
So you mentioned a bunch
of different providers
providing agents in a
different ways to do it.
What's unique about Boomi's approach?
- Yeah, so several different things.
One is being able to
observe agentic behavior
and providing governance
guardrails, that sort of thing.
That's at the agent layer.
But the tooling layer is also something
that's very interesting as well.
- How so?
- And so...
Well, like creating processes.
A business process,
like, for those of you who are familiar
with hire to retire, order-to-cash
or any type of back office
workflow, just as an example,
that can be built by whatever
integration platform you use,
within our framework, we
can turn those into tools.
We can turn those into
tools via RAG pipeline, MCP.
We can do a lot of different techniques
to make sure that whatever processes,
whatever access to data,
whether they're file data,
database data, endpoints for APIs,
those all get exposed,
created, abstracted,
whatever the case is, we
can make that all useful.
The other thing that we can do as well
is really separate out what it means
to integrate applications and also data.
And so what I mean by
that is we can validate
how different agentic systems
are performing their task and compare that
with what we think they
should do deterministically
and bring the human in the
loop like you're talking about.
And what this does is it allows our users
to gain trust from the overall platform.
And there's much, much more.
And the the last thing I'll bring up
and I think is a real, real big separator
from us and others,
that is, with Boomi,
you create in the cloud
and you run wherever you want to.
If security is important to you,
if privacy is important to you
and your integrations need to,
and your tooling needs to
abide by whatever processes
and whatever policies that
you have for your enterprise,
with Boomi, you can do the sorts of things
to keep your data path separate
from the actual design time.
Runtime is separate from the design time.
So if you're about
things like sovereignty,
especially as we move
into a different geopolitical situation,
if you do business internationally
outside of the United States in any way,
you can install your runtimes
anywhere you want to,
as many or as few of them as necessary
to execute whatever tasks.
So those agents ingenix
systems would be able
to take advantage of
the integration features
that we have there.
- Really allows that flexibility.
- Huge flexibility and
complete differentiator.
- Great, Barry something to add?
- I have that come up
a lot in terms of GDPR.
You know, a lot of people
have GDPR regulations
that they're concerned with,
you know, where the data exists.
You know, maybe by penalty
of, you know, local law,
you have a mandate that says
your data must exist and must run
and must execute and stay
within the logical boundaries
of that geographic region.
So, a lot of times, Boomi's
runtime the separation
between our runtime and our platform.
The fact that the
runtime can live anywhere
really plays nicely into that concern.
So a lot of business comes
our way for that reason.
The other kind of one thing
I'll kind of chime in on
is Boomi's vendor agnostic approach.
You know, like, there's a lot
of folks out in the market
that kind of do what we do,
and they might be tied to a larger company
that wants to sell you larger objectives.
So not necessarily that the
product really is all that bad
'cause there's a lot of
good competitors out there,
but their roadmaps will be in service
to those larger objectives,
the things that they want sell you.
So the things that their
roadmap will express
is not so vendor agnostic,
whereas Boomi tends to
be a very even play field
among all of our vendors
that we deal with.
- Yep.
- Awesome, great.
So I've got some history with Boomi,
and what I remember is it being an amazing
integration platform, right?
Best in the business.
And now that we have agents and MCP
and all these other techniques,
is integration still important?
- Yeah.
Like, this shows integration
is one of the reasons
why going from prototype to production
is very difficult to do.
And without having the proper
integration steps, it's hard.
I wanna redefine what integration
actually means though.
There was a time when it meant
to take two or more disparate systems,
expose APIs or expose away an interface
to be able to have those
systems connect with each other,
transform and move data accordingly
relative to a process of
service or something like this.
And when I say process,
I mean like a business process
in in our nomenclature.
The way that I would
define integration now
includes a couple of other elements.
It does include automation with it.
The ability to not only
take a manual process
and, you know, automate pieces of it,
but create end-to-end automations,
and then also orchestration.
So orchestration becomes the element
where you can create your
programs, your services,
your agents, whatever it is,
and have full and utter
control over the governance
of those created assets.
And so with that,
we need things like the
ability to do simple things
like ETL or virtual ETL
or the ability to capture changes in data
as it flows from a transaction system
to an analytical system, and back again.
The ability to connect in
real-time or near real-time
how different systems are
interacting with each other
and updating the metadata accordingly,
and all of the data needs to
be where it it needs to go.
The other thing is APIs.
Making sure that you can not
only expose or create them
but also manage them as well.
Regardless to, you know,
what type of API gateway
or however many API gateways you have
of different flavors and varieties.
And the last thing is
to adapt to the changes
in the AI landscape as they come.
So, for instance, we were
talking about RAG pipelines.
Everybody familiar with RAG,
Retrieval-Augmented Generation?
A lot of head nods.
Okay, good.
And if you're not,
this is something that's
been really in the market
with 19 different architectural types,
really, in the last couple of years.
Well, this new technology,
MCP, has come along
and provided a different way
to turn tools into very
accessible resources
for agents specifically.
So Model Context Protocol and
context engineering in general
has changed and adapted,
but we have to, because we're
an integration platform,
we're not stuck in older paradigms.
We can change and adapt to new
technologies that come out.
So when we're talking about A2A
or any type of agent to agent protocol
or any type of north-south protocol,
like MCP as an example, we're there.
And for people like me
who are looking five to
10 years down the road,
trying to figure out
what that future world
is gonna look like and make
sure that we stay consistent
with what we have now to the
builds, then that's what we do.
So an integration platform
needs to be modern,
flexible, and adaptive.
- Yeah, I think...
I mean, that's a great point,
and Boomi's obviously illustrated
an ability over the years,
I've known you, to continue
to evolve the platform,
to be able to incorporate and adopt
the different changing
in protocols or access
or governance or whatever
happens to be what's next.
- Exactly.
- Which is great.
Barry, you have something to add?
- Yeah, it also speaks to,
I mentioned before, vendor agnostic.
You know, we can be the MCP tools
that you use in your agents,
even if it was developed
on another framework,
or, you know, we support MCP
so you could develop tools
on another platform, and
we'll accept those tools
to be able to be used by the AI agents
that you could create using Boomi.
The other thing that's worth noting is,
you know, I know, Ben, you go
way back with the platform,
but Boomi was actually,
it's been around since 2006.
So, you know, by reference,
this would be around the time
that we were using flip
phones and Blackberries.
Mike probably had a goatee.
I had an embarrassing boy band
haircut with frosted tips.
It was really very tragic.
But it was around that time
that Boomi came up with
this process canvas idea,
and it's been very resilient
over the last two decades.
And the reason for it is,
is it's so darn easy to use.
Like, it is this, you know, drag and drop
wizard-driven thing that you
don't necessarily have to be,
or you know, be a full
scale developer to use.
But we've managed to model
that approach over the years
to be able to do things now
like to have an agent step
to be able to support RAG,
to be able to do things with MCP.
So in that way, Boomi has
evolved to be what it is today.
- All right, so we're gonna have...
- I have one thing I do wanna add.
- Add away.
- So this is about human agency.
Right?
- Yes.
- So I wanna bring it back
to the human for a second.
- Let's do that 'cause
we're all human, right?
- So, well, maybe most
of you are, I don't know.
- You're dicey.
- I'm dicey.
Like, honestly, human
agency is important to me.
So every morning...
This might sound trite, but it's true.
When I am researching
something for the future,
I think about how this technology
is going to impact the way I work,
the way my kids are gonna work,
if they're gonna have jobs, you know?
Are we all worried about that?
Maybe a little bit.
You know?
It's concerning.
These are human concerns, right?
How is our society
ultimately going to change
and how is the technology
that we're going to implement
going to be indicative of that?
And what I think needs to happen there
and what platforms like ours
do, and now many others,
is we've talked about these
democratic transformations
in technology for a long time.
And when we democratize technology,
we make it accessible for
people to use and use well.
And the really neat thing about this tech
and where we're at in this
moment in time is we don't know
where the jobs of the
future are going to be
or where society is going to be.
And the accessibility
of what agentic types of systems provide
is it allows everybody to
have access to be a builder.
Everybody in here speaks
some human language, I would assume.
- I would hope so.
- Yeah.
And any of your colleagues
who is a non-programmer
that speaks the language that
you do is now a developer,
just like you are.
And whether you're a vibe coder,
which is popular in today's parlance,
or whether you are a seasoned veteran
who's been coding for
all of her or his life,
or their life, it's...
These are...
You know, these worlds are converging
in interesting and unique ways.
And so platforms like ours make
it accessible for the human
to actually create a sense of agency
within the platform itself.
And what's really neat
about that, you know,
as I'm looking out, I'm thinking,
"What is your digital twin
or digital twins that
you're going to be creating
as an agent to augment what you do,
to change the way you behave,
to act on your behalf, knowing
what your constraints are?"
These are all things that are accessible
in platforms like ours
because we're giving everybody
the kind of agency necessary
to be able to build the tools
that are gonna model a future world.
So it's up to us to
figure out what that is.
Right now, super early days, for sure.
- It is.
And I'll ask a another polling question
just to get some audience participation.
Does anybody here have a part of their job
that's not their favorite?
(Michael and Barry laughing)
Pretty much all of us, right?
- I love expense reports.
- Yeah, well there you go.
Perfect one, right?
Where I see this technology,
and especially Boomi's platform,
helping us as human beings is
finding ways to use the tools,
create agents to do the parts of our job
that we don't particularly,
that are repetitive,
that could be automated
or have a workflow associated with them
to make our lives genuinely better, right?
So freeing up time for all of you
to do the parts of your job you do enjoy,
that probably add more value
both to you personally,
back to the human, but also
to your organization, right?
Solving the next problem, being creative,
really tapping into what we're great at,
which is complex critical
thinking as a human being
and being creative, solving problems.
- Well, I hope you're right
about the complex critical thinking bit.
- Yeah.
- You might have seen some reports lately
that we're getting dumber over time.
- Depends on who you ask.
- It depends on who you ask.
But if we seed our critical
thinking to another system,
this is going to create
interesting new challenges
that will emerge,
that we're gonna have to solve
for those problems as well.
My kids, for instance, who
are both at university,
one very much uses AI,
the other one very much does not.
I notice a difference in how
they think about their world.
Not that the one who uses
AI doesn't think critically.
This person might...
That child actually does
think very critically.
My hope is that we all remember this
as we're governing what
we're doing in our jobs
or whatever we're going
to introduce agents into
in our day-to-day lives.
- And I'll add this.
The World Economic Forum did
a jobs report last January.
I encourage those...
I see a nod, so good.
If you haven't seen it, highly recommend.
It's free download.
But it has a chart of the skills
that are gonna be in high demand in 2030,
which isn't that far along.
But it makes logical sense,
a lot of the skills are human skills.
Critical thinking, learning,
influence, communicating,
these kinds of things.
If you think about it,
if we have agents doing the mundane things
that we don't want to do,
it frees us up to do the
things that are uniquely human,
and therefore will be more valuable.
So I encourage your sons and daughters
to go review the skills that, as parents,
we want to recommend them seeking.
And all of you, as you continue
your career development,
look at those 'cause you'll see, again,
a demand for those human skills
are gonna come at a
higher, you know, value,
I think, in due course.
- Yeah, there's the other thing.
I do want a polling question here.
- Please.
- How many...
Do I have any liberal arts people?
With a liberal arts
background in the room?
- Not a one.
No one.
- Not one?
- Oh, there's one.
- Oh, we got one.
- Excellent, there's always one.
- Outstanding.
So I was at Cornell giving
a lecture to grad students
and undergrads about a month ago.
And in the grad student
session, room full of engineers.
Awesome stuff.
Different kinds of
engineers, top bright people,
all of that sort of thing.
We had one lone liberal arts person.
And I turned to that person and said,
you are going to be doing
very well in this new economy.
And the reason why is
because liberal arts people,
I know firsthand 'cause
my undergraduate degree
is in liberal arts as well
with German linguistics
and international affairs,
and then later, computer science.
But those...
In liberal arts, you're
taught to think critically,
be creative, have novel
approaches to things.
So, it's good.
So if your kids are
interested in liberal arts.
- Encourage, encourage.
- Yeah, encourage them
to go down that path.
- It's kind of interesting
how we used to place,
you know, like, an onus
on being an idea person
'cause it kind of made what you could do.
You couldn't do the implementation of it,
you just come up with the idea.
Now, what you're saying,
there's greater value placed
on that versus implementation
because now implementation
has gotten that much easier.
- Well, and from an
engineering perspective too,
all the engineers that I've
worked with, you know, at Penn
and like everywhere else that I've been,
they're all super creative too.
Creativity is going to have
a changing and adapting role.
It's the critical
thinking that we all have
where going to be able to
govern how these agents work.
But those are elements of human growth
and where agents are gonna get
better and better over time
or have a chance to get
better and better over time.
- All right, you just mentioned it,
and we're gonna ask you
to dig in a little deeper
to how important is governance.
And most importantly, how does
Boomi help with governance?
- Yeah, so governance means
a lot of different things.
We talked about autonomy,
we talked about an agent and what that is.
What I really want to get into,
and, sorry, I'm flipping
around here, is this.
So there's a newer version of this slide,
but this is a two by two
where I think governance
really comes into trust versus autonomy.
The more we trust a system,
the more we're going to
give that system ability
to act in the world.
And if we just think about us as humans
and how we interact with each other,
and I don't mean to
anthropomorphize agents in general
that we are talking about,
you know, in this conference,
but I'm gonna in a little bit just
to give us a mental model to work off of.
If we think about how we
trust a coworker, ourselves,
you know, somebody else, our
children to do something,
we'll give them more
freedom to do that thing.
And so at this conference
I was at a couple,
about a month ago, we
came up with this matrix,
which we have a human in the loop
where we've got high
trust but low autonomy.
We have human on the loop,
which is high autonomy
but not necessarily high
trust at this point.
And then the polar opposites.
In the upper right-hand
corner, this is full autonomy.
When we think of like autonomous vehicles,
you know, operating here
in the Las Vegas area,
that would be an example of
something that's a trusted agent
or an expert system on
a manufacturing line.
Those are examples of that.
In the lower left-hand corner though,
where we refuse as humans
to give agency to an agentic system
in either context or in
production or in processing,
this is ripe for disruption.
So, in other words, if
one has manual processes
that they're going to do and
not willing to seed autonomy,
this is going to create a disruptive case.
And so what I think will
happen at this particular point
is that if companies that
you are competing against
or organizations where you are
stifled by not using agents
or not moving fast enough to,
those types of companies
are opening themselves up to disruption.
Conversely, we're
probably not going to just
give the keys of the
kingdom to an agent full on
for a very, very long time,
until such time that
trust has been established
with those agents to
do that sort of thing.
So the goal is to move from
this lower left-hand box
into the upper left-hand, or
the lower right-hand at least,
so that we can have the human
involved in the governance
and processing context provision
for that particular agent.
And so where we have
this today, for instance,
is something simple like
a human in the loop.
Human provides the context,
the agent processes.
This would be an example of using,
say, a chat system of some kind.
You're providing a prompt, it
goes out and does the work.
You're not doing the work,
but largely that is a real
thing that we can do today.
Human on the loop is something like,
the agents going out and finding something
and checking in with you
to see if that's okay.
In our platform,
and one of the differentiators
is this validation step.
So, for instance, if you have systems
where you've got two
different addresses for you,
one in your old house
that you just lived in
and maybe the new house that you moved to,
that needs to be updated by a human.
Today we can do this deterministically.
But at scale, if agents
are going to be determining
whether or not there's
an A case or a B case
or a red case or a blue
case or a green case
and needs a human to act
as the final arbitrary
of what's going to happen,
that is the case where
the human is on the loop
in that particular point.
So, the way that Boomi handles that
is we provide all of the tools
to be able, you know, to
govern this sort of approach.
Giving humans more trust,
allowing humans to see
what the agents are doing,
and giving more trust in the
process for the human to move
from this lower left
to the other quadrants.
- Yeah, Barry.
- [Barry] I think that's
particularly valuable
when you're talking
about anomaly detection.
You know, like, let's say that
there happens to be an agent
that is existing and that you've created
and you wanna make sure
that you've established
a baseline of executions
so that any spikes or
abnormalities that should occur,
that you're detecting and
then providing governance
and, like Mike was saying,
being that human in the loop
that can determine
whether either I need to
adjust those thresholds
or something has legitimately gone wrong
and I need to be able
to either kill the agent
or act responsibility to alter the agent
to make this work better.
- [Ben] You know what?
I really like this focus
on trust and autonomy.
Has everybody used an
assistant of some kind
and had a hallucination of some kind?
Everybody?
Like, that is...
It happens, and that can
erode trust with the humans
or the people who are trying
to adopt these systems.
And so as practitioners,
we've gotta find ways to
validate and make sure
that we're reducing the hallucinations
or the times where the
system gets it wrong.
Otherwise, the adoption of said system
is gonna not be where we need it to be,
to solve whatever problem
we intended to solve.
So I really like how you've laid this out
because it is a sliding scale,
and you're on it somewhere.
- Somewhere.
- [Ben] And some processes
may be in different parts over time,
but ideally, this gives you
a roadmap on how to proceed.
- Yeah, and they could move
in and out of these stages as well.
The other thing,
just on the point that
you mentioned about trust,
and I know Barry's got a lot to say too.
The more we trust and the
more we seed authority,
we also run a risk as well.
- Indeed.
- 'Cause if these agents
are performing at,
you talked about hallucination,
let's say we get to a stage
where an agent is hallucinating
less than 1% of the time.
That could lull us into submission.
- Yeah.
- And when that happens,
this is exactly where we need to go.
Forced autonomy, all right,
the agent's gonna do all
of the automated work,
but we're gonna need to do some auditing
and spot checking and this sort of thing.
And so that's important.
- And kind of thinking
back to that original stat
that you have about the 95%,
it's probably fair to say
that there's a fair percentage in that 95%
where AI agents were being
asked to do something
that probably an AI agent
shouldn't be asked to do,
maybe was just best left
as a deterministic process.
- Indeed.
- All right.
We're gonna pivot now to Boomi's AI story.
Barry, if you would, give us a feel for,
at a high level, what that has been.
- So, Boomi's AI stories
is really interesting
in that you can kind of break it out
into three different ways, really,
that we've incorporated AI.
One is the way in which
we enable you to do
kind of, let's say,
AI-related things using Boomi.
Like we said that Boomi
has a process canvas
that allows you to be able to
have an orchestration layer,
allows you to be able to
accomplish your AI objectives
within your organization,
and even to be able to create agents
that could call other agents
and could call other agents
and do things like that.
That's fairly, you know,
rudimentary within Boomi right now.
There is the AI that
we've built into the tool
to make using Boomi a more
natural language process thing.
So as to democratize innovation,
like you were mentioning before, Mike.
But then, of course,
the thing that's really most interesting
for the purposes of this
conversation is Agent Studio.
In Agent Studio, we provide
you with an agent designer
so that you can build AI agents
using natural language processing.
So you could literally come in and say,
"I'd like to create an agent
that does this, this and this."
And then Boomi will use AI to create AI
and it will actually allow a business user
to come in and create their own AI agents.
It will actually create the
disposition of the chat,
you know, the ChatGPT that you can use,
it will go in, create all
the tasks, the instructions,
you can assign it tooling,
you know, so that if that AI agent
needs to be able to reference
other sources of information,
other data sources, other APIs,
it will easily enable you to do so.
And we also offer you a test harness
for being able to test out
the AI agents that you create
prior to deployment.
Now, the other thing that's
pretty exciting about that
is that from a governance perspective,
we provide you with Agent Control Tower.
Agent Control Tower
allows you a complete look
at all of the agents inside
of your entire environment.
And I said before,
Boomi specializes in
being vendor agnostic.
We don't let you just track agents
that are created in Boomi,
we also allow you to be able to create
and use agents in other systems
and have them be tracked
in Agent Control Tower.
So you get this full ecosystem
view and, you know, this...
A little demo here goes.
Moves pretty quick, but if
you see the first screen,
it has a bunch of little bubbles on it.
Those are agents that are all,
each different color
represents a different vendor.
Whether it be ServiceNow,
whether it be AWS,
whether it be Boomi,
we can connect to the frameworks
and pull in all of the agents
that you happen to create.
So it gives you the ability
to be able to have monitoring
and compliance dashboards.
It gives you the ability
to be able to kind of see
and flag anomalies and even
set thresholds for anomalies.
So that if anything should go wrong
with any agent in your entire ecosystem,
you could drill down,
you could actually get
an introspective look
at all of the agents and what they do,
and then you can make
adjustments as needed.
Maybe you need to kill the agent,
maybe you need to adjust the thresholds.
It gives you a full look
at all of the agents
and it could help you
eliminate sprawl, agent sprawl,
and shadow IT in your organization
because it'll bring to light agents
you might not have even known existed.
- [Michael] Yeah, and
it's a really good way
to get IT and the
business aligned as well.
Just on that note.
- [Ben] That's not important.
(group laughing)
Just kidding.
Barry can you dive a little
deeper into how Boomi
helps customers operationalize their data?
The AI is only gonna be as good
as the data it has access to.
So how's Boomi helping there?
- Yeah, 100%.
So Boomi, actually, if
I could go back here,
but you see that we have four core tenets
within our Boomi enterprise platform.
There's integration and automation,
which we've talked about exhaustively.
There's data management as well.
And data management allows you
to be able to cleanse and enrich your data
in essence to be able to
make that data AI-ready.
So it gives you the ability
to be able to take a look at data
coming from various different sources
to be able to establish this
within a hub and spoke model.
The middle of which can establish
golden records within Boomi
that has the data cleanse stage,
de-duped using fuzzy
logic matches if need be,
and provide AI-ready
data that can feed models
or can be used in contextualized
prompts and queries
to be able to enrich those
queries via something like RAG
that you mentioned earlier.
RAG being Retrieval-Augmented Generation.
But the other thing too is that, you know,
within those four pillars,
we have integration,
automation, data management,
and we also have API management.
'Cause, of course, we
understand the importance
of being able to use APIs and access APIs
in the agents that you create as well.
So Boomi has made significant investment
in being able to bring to light
basically an enterprise-grade
API management platform
that is now in the Gartner Magic Quadrant
for API management.
So, I think we're the only vendor actually
that can make that claim
where we're in the Magic
Quadrant for Gartner,
for both integration and API management.
- Great.
All right, so Michael mentioned governance
and you mentioned anomalies.
So touch on, Barry, if you would,
how Boomi helps both identify anomalies,
what kind of anomalies,
and then importantly,
like, what should we be concerned about?
Why would these...
Why would there be an anomaly?
- Yeah, I mean there's a
lot of different anomalies
that can exist within, you
know, what you're doing.
You know, like we have,
I think I thought I had a slide here.
Nope, I didn't.
Okay, so as it turns out,
when we're talking about things
that can potentially go wrong, you know,
it could be a total number of invocations.
So anything that could
alert you as the human
to something that could be
going wrong with an agent
or a set of agents that might be,
you know, one agent calling another
or making some deterministic
path of execution
that it shouldn't.
And a lot of times within booming,
even with an Agent Control
Tower, we can do things like,
we can flag total invocations,
we can flag errors,
we can flag hops, you
know, along the route
that would indicate that, you
know, maybe there's something
that has happened, that hasn't happened,
or doesn't usually happen.
And in that way, we could
do monitoring and reporting,
we could do logging.
We can even set up Boomi
processes that can fix
or address those issues,
be it either autonomously
or with a human in the loop to do so.
- Yeah, there's some other
stuff I will add too.
Also following the prompt
and sequence of executions
for a reasoning model.
So, you know, inside of the designer,
you know, we're using a Claude
or an Anthropic family of models.
Pretty soon, it's going to
be bring your own as well.
That's for next year, which will be great.
The key here is the prompts
that we as humans use
to govern or to create
or kick off a process,
those need to be followed,
and all of the steps
that an agent is doing
to being able to grab data,
what the source data is,
all of that is logged.
And so when you can see all
of the actions of the agent
and if it is commensurate
to the governance guardrails
that you put in to your framework,
this is how you're going to know
when everything is going right.
And when it's not, then there
are flags that are sent out
or stoppages that will happen
so the agent can't move forward.
- Yeah, I've seen IT operations,
actually, agents that have been made
to basically examine logs for anomalies,
just for that purpose.
Just to be able to flag
just anomalous sets of execution in logs.
So you can use AI agents
to basically keep AI agents in line.
- All right, so we all work for companies.
And so why don't we make this real
and give some real world examples.
You just touched on one of the logs,
but let's explore some of
the real world examples
and business outcomes that
agents are are impacting.
- Yeah, so I was looking actually
at this slide in particular.
We kind of glossed over this one.
But here, you see...
This is kind of a busy slide,
but you get to see all the
different kind of things
that you can use and create agents
and what people have used agents for,
whether they be personal assistance,
coding assistance, ChatBot summaries.
You know, as far as how
I've seen customers use
Boomi AI agents, like, I've
seen financial reporting.
That's a big one.
You know, where people, if
you're doing expense reports,
you wanna be able to flag-
- There you go.
- What should be thresholds
in expense reporting.
Even in Boomi, we happen to
use something called ChatB,
which actually allows us
to be able to make queries,
you know, for internal folks within Boomi
so that they're not going out
to ChatGPT to query things,
but they wanna get
Boomi-specific knowledge
and drill down very deep within
Boomi to be able to get it.
We use our own personal RAG
implementation within that
for our own internal GPT
operations that we're using.
Did you have?
- Yeah, I definitely did.
So we also do these agentic workshops
for enterprises as well.
And in there, as you
see down in the bottom,
we go from the knowledge
base type of use case
that Barry was just talking about
to something that's very focused
on certain industries as well.
One of them is in accounting.
One of the projects that
we're working on now
is saving 27,000 hours of human time
in order to do reconciliation
between invoices and payments.
Every company has this problem.
The degree to which manual processes
are involved in that in
most companies is high.
- Yep.
- And so one of the areas
that this could be a quick
and big win for with very minimal risk,
which is what I would advise
any first agent out the
door to do, is that one.
That reconciliation process can be tricky,
depending on how many child companies
your parent might have.
But in general, if you're
looking for a quick win
with a lot of payout, that's a big one.
- What are some other areas
that you guys have seen,
you know, quick realization of value?
- Actually one thing
I wanted to kind of do
before we even answer that
is I wanted to show for
Mike's group for a minute
because they offer like one-day workshops
where literally Boomi will come in,
take a look at your business,
be able to offer you
complete one-day workshops
where you can get hands-on using Boomi,
creating agents, solving your problems,
and then creating what would be a roadmap
for how you can use AI
agents in your business
and how Boomi can help you get there.
So if you happen to be one of those people
that happened to raise your hand earlier
and was looking for,
you know, some guidance
in regards to ideas you may have,
but you really don't know
where to go to get there,
this is a great one day workshop.
You know, put that down on
your list of things to do.
Reach out to, you know,
either Mike Bachman or myself.
I'm Barry.Gerdsen@Boomi.com.
And request one of these workshops,
and we'd be happy to
set you up and come in.
They're completely free,
and we have a mandate
to be able to do quite
a bit of them, so...
- Excellent.
Any other, you know, quick hits
or, Michael, from these
workshops that are notable,
that have that light bulb
moment for for a customer?
- Yeah, so the quick wins,
you know, are something that's gonna be
a knowledge base type of win as well.
We implemented, we went
from prototype to production
inside of Boomi using ChatB
within several months.
But the prototype was literally two days
to be able to create that.
And going through security,
going through governance checks,
going through validation of
different models that were used,
updates on RAG pipelines,
that's what takes the time,
and it's just making sure
that you get enough eyes
on the particular problem early on.
But these types of knowledge base systems
are really good ones
for good wholesome wins.
The problem is the ROI
is hard to define there.
Whereas in these other
types of reconciliations,
if we go to finance and
we go to accounting,
these are where we can start
to pick up some real wins.
And so in these workshops,
we're not just bringing in IT folks,
we're bringing in line of
business operators and executives.
And if an executive can build an agent
and then start to think about her problem
as it pertains to her day to day-
- Broadly, yeah.
- All of a sudden,
doors open up.
And now it's not about determining
how to build a piece of software,
it's like, how do I solve
this particular persnickety problem
that has been elusive for so long?
Can an agent help me solve that?
Let's go and fail fast if it can't,
but let's iterate on this
and see how well it can work.
And that has been going over really well.
- I like that a lot.
All right, so a lot of
our attendees at re:Invent
are part of a company
that has some software
that faces out to customers.
And so how is AI and agents
being incorporated into the UI
to make their software,
their service more
effective and efficient?
- So, within Boomi,
one of the things that
we have done in the past
and that we're actually expanding,
and I'll tell you how we're
expanding in a moment.
But one of the things that we offer,
and I do a lot of work on the OEM side.
That's the reason why you see
my sample application here.
It's called OEM+, but
it's called EmbedKit.
And what it allows you to do
is it allows you to be able
to create your integrations
in Boomi and then be able to,
if you had one to many customers,
you can actually give
them a curated marketplace
of the integrations
that you intend for them
by easily just dropping
in either Vanilla JS
or React components that we give you
that allow you to be able
to just surface an interface
kind of like you see here.
So imagine your application
with these JS components inputted into it
that allow you to be able
to give people easy ways,
and this would be tailored
toward business users,
to be able to self-service
their own integrations.
So you just basically give them
last mile configuration details
to be able to provide integrations.
Now, that's something
that we've been providing
people the ability to do.
It's highly popular.
But we've since expanded it
to also include AI agents.
So you see an example here where,
if what you want to do is you
have an idea for an agent,
once again you can use
Boomi's Agent Studio
to be able to, you know,
use natural language
to create the AI agent,
and then to be able to just drop
these React or JS components
into your application,
and it gives your users
an easy way to consume
the AI agent that you've created
inside of your application.
So you can get up and
running inside of a week
doing something like this,
and it gives you an easy way
to offer AI to your customers.
So if this is something
that's interesting,
again, it's barry.gerdsen@boomi.com
- And those are governed
agents too, right?
- Yes, absolutely.
Yeah, the nice thing about one part
of that agent creation process
is that we include guardrails,
you know, so that it is secure.
You know, like, we can actually make sure,
you know, during the wizard
that we guide you through
to be able to create AI agents,
that you can go through and
you can say things like,
you know, use a RegX expression
that would be a social security number,
so that the agent knows not to put
any, you know, sensitive
information to the screen.
You can also warn on content.
You can warn on subject
so as to keep your agents
from doing things that they
really shouldn't be doing.
Or to be misappropriated
to do something they shouldn't be doing.
- All right, Barry, can
you tell us a bit about MCP
and what it is and how
Boomi, you know, enables it
or how Boomi interacts with MCP?
- Sure, so MCP stands for
Model Context Protocol,
and it is a way for you
to be able to converse
and to be able to reach out
to tools in a standard way.
So, let's say, that you
were creating an AI agent,
and you needed an AI agent
to have the proper
information that it needed,
but that information comes
from some external system.
And you didn't necessarily know
how to be able to get that information,
what that external information
can be offered up as
is an MCP tool.
And Boomi supports both the ability
to act as a gateway for these MCP tools.
So anything within Boomi
that you saw before,
whether it happens to be an integration,
whether it happens to be an API,
whether it happens to be a data record,
any of those things can be
offered up as an MCP tool
because within our API management tool,
you can literally flick a switch,
and it becomes an MCP server
that allows you to serve
out Boomi capabilities
for your AI agents that may be created
either in Boomi or not in Boomi.
Again, we are very vendor agnostic.
Nice thing about this is
it gives you a standard way
to be able to offer your AI agents
the information that it
needs to be effective.
- Outstanding.
All right, so as we wrap things up,
we've got five minutes left,
I wanna go start with Michael,
and then we'll end with Barry.
Just words of advice to our audience
on how to get started,
if they haven't started,
and any best practices to be successful.
- Yeah, the first thing
is, you know, build in,
like, time to failure for yourself.
Really play around with agents,
really understand whatever ecosystem
that you're using today.
It's super helpful to get hands on
and really not be afraid of the tech.
And this room is probably not that...
So you're probably out there
and doing all sorts of
things aggressively.
One thing that I can say is this.
This is a fast moving market,
and things are changing pretty readily.
- Today.
- We have...
Today, like, things already changed today.
You know, they're approaching,
I think we might be close
to 5 million models,
actual generative AI models out there.
Everybody, all databases
or many databases now offer the ability
to accept vector
embeddings and store those
and have those retrievable.
MCP and other agentic protocols
are springing up all over the place.
And the important thing is
to stay ahead of all of this.
But adopt the platforms
or consider platforms,
whether it's ours or somebody else's,
that are adaptive to the
changes that are coming.
And so get the hands dirty.
Come over and see us at the booth.
We're at the Venetian.
And learn more is a good first step.
And I'm also gonna bring
in the human element again-
- Good.
- Because this is critical.
When we're thinking about
the future of the systems
that we wanna create to make
our lives better at work
or make society better truly,
it's important to understand
what the limits of these
particular tools are.
There are camps which say
that you can do everything with agents,
and, you know, just dive in.
I caution that if that's your approach.
I would say, from a human perspective,
what I would want is to engage
as your level of understanding increases
and knowing what the limits
of agents are or systems are,
what the limits of these models are,
how to use these models in
conjunction with each other
in order to achieve outcomes,
how to ensure and
guaranteed structured output
so that you can have better overall
goal resolution at the end.
These are the types of things
that we need to do as practitioners.
And for those of you who are
model creators in the room,
there's gonna be wild
changes coming there,
you know, in a keynote-
- Yeah, we're gonna help.
- Yeah.
Yeah, AWS is doing a lot with that,
like, neuromorphic systems in general.
Abstractions the way that humans
visualize information and context.
This is not available in LLMs today.
So getting to AGI probably,
I don't know where you stand on that.
But from my point of view,
probably not gonna get to this supermodel
with a super world view
at our current state.
And so what that means is
there's going to be changing
and adaptive technology.
And if those things can have APIs
that we can expose or automate,
we can also govern them with
the right tools as well.
So, as we as humans try
to emulate what we do,
the processes that we have,
the biases that we wanna
remove from all of our systems,
all of those sorts of things
require heavy governance
and a good platform that's adaptive.
So what I would say is, come check us out.
- Love it.
Barry.
- Yeah.
I mean, you said a lot of
good things in there, Mike,
but I'll also add, choose a framework.
I think, like, a lot of times,
a framework will just provide
you with the ease of use,
all of the kind of capabilities
and the things that you should look for
that we've talked about
over the last hour.
A lot of that stuff's gonna be built in.
And it doesn't have to be Boomi.
We very much like it if it was,
but if it's not, you could
choose something like AWS,
you could choose one of the
other vendors out there.
But I think you'll find,
you know, the ability
to fail fast will happen
better and easier, you
know, with a framework
if you're going that route with it.
The other thing I would once
again encourage you to do
is to seek out one of
those kind of workshops
that I was talking about to
get your hands dirty with it.
If you haven't so far,
it's a great way to start.
Like, it will kind of take
down your learning time
to what would be, you know, by
a factor of 10, I would say,
just by devoting one day to it
'cause you'll just get
all the tips, the tricks.
All the things that we've learned
over the benefit of
the last several years,
we'll be able to impart
that knowledge upon you.
- And get the business and IT
all better aligns around this as well.
- Yep, all right.
- Gentlemen, thank you so very much.
Everyone, if you would
give a round of applause
for my esteemed guests.
Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
Thanks so much.
- Thank you.
Thanks to all of you as well.